merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues monsieur le ministre les
importants épisode de sécheresse de
l'été dernier n'était finalement que les
prémices d'une pénurie qui s'installe
désormais dans la durée à ce jour nous
avons deux mois de retard sur la
recharge des nappes phréatiques une
sécheresse hivernale inédite l'accès à
l'eau potable que l'on croyait garantie
à tous nos concitoyens est aujourd'hui
menacé d'autant plus que nous constatons
la réduction des débits des cours d'eau
qui entraîne une concentration des
micropollants et pose un vrai problème
sanitaire pour la potabilité de l'eau
au-delà de nos concitoyens la tension
sur l'eau a bien entendu un impact sur
le fonctionnement de nos entreprises de
notre agriculture les cultures l'élevage
mais aussi nos centrales nucléaires le
Sénat a mené un certain nombre de
travaux autour de cette problématique en
présentant plusieurs pistes pour
améliorer notre gestion de l'eau que ce
soit la conciliation des usages la
sensibilisation du grand public à la
sobriété les retenues d'eau ou la
nécessaire modernisation de l'irrigation
pour nos agriculteurs les propositions
ne manquent pas mais elles ont besoin de
financement monsieur le ministre dans ce
contexte qui nous préoccupe tous
plusieurs départements ont déjà été
placés en situation d'alerte sécheresse
mais il est évident que le temps n'est
plus à la réaction mais à l'anticipation
indispensable et à l'adaptation de notre
pays au changement climatique monsieur
le ministre ma question est simple
pouvez-vous nous exposer de façon très
concrète votre poétique politique
d'anticipation sur l'eau à défaut
d'avoir anticipé la crise de l'énergie
le gouvernement prendra-t-il toutes les
mesures nécessaires afin de faire face à
la crise de l'eau